[Music]
many important moments in black history
have been left out of american history
books
for example many americans have never
heard of the tuskegee airmen the first
official group of
african-american pilots to serve in the
u.s military
they risked their lives defending our
country during world war
ii while also facing the discrimination
of the jim crow era but
did you know that there was another
group of african-american pilots that
came in just before them
i didn't until i saw this documentary
last night take a look
[Music]
i sleep now this here is the story of
the real
first black airmen of world war ii now a
few people know this but the tuskegee
airmen red tails weren't the only black
pilots in world war
ii before the red tails they were us
the blue feathers we didn't have the
training that the red tails did but
we had something better heart
no one ever talks about us blue feathers
but we were the stars
of the tuskegee institute the red tails
were excellent pilots
we all agree with this but the blue
feathers had something those red tails
never had
zero impulse control there were nine of
us
and one fateful day july 18
1941 we took off to defend our country
in the war
davis was the first to go while he was
in the air he radioed me and
said think i can get into outer space
and i replied no you could not i begged
him not to but
it was too late he flew straight up
until he ran out of fuel
this fuel a plane would plummet to the
earth sometime later and kill more
people
then washington and townsend decided to
get in their planes and race each other
a plane race who the hell ever heard of
a plane race
i tried to tell them it was a bad idea
and that we were meant to fight for our
country
they told me to eat [ __ ]
yes they did they smashed into each
other
instantly and died garrison
martins and green decided to see if they
can get in their planes and do the
electric slide
for a second they could
but eventually they died
smith and lamar decided to see if they
could reach out of their planes and
high-five each other during the flyby
they could not they died
the red tails were going to be some of
the most famous pilots the world has
ever known
whereas not a single member of the blue
feather survived that first day
fun fact not a single one of us lived
long enough to be killed by the enemy
even i died this is a reenactment
remember that plane that davis flew in
the outer space
well as soon as i landed safe and sound
davis's plane smashed me like a pancake
that's why every year on this very day
we celebrate
blue feathers day by doing something you
shouldn't do
jug
oh yeah come on come here let me slap
you
come on ah slap fight
ah i got you that time didn't i come on
come here
i get you look at me coming for you here
he is
they call me come and slap me that's
what they call me
[Applause]
you